[creator] Okay, I'm back after a little bit and
[creator] Ended up starting phase four. I don't know if this is in the other one
[creator] there are some issues like
[creator] Whenever I was testing some of the audio didn't work and 3d wasn't loading
[creator] so I got all that fixed and
[creator] This is the game now
[creator] which
[creator] Graphics wise I like the 3d
[creator] meteors and everything I feel like I'm going way too fast though also don't
[creator] really like this like targeting I don't like the outlines also like the old
[creator] background more but I will say I do like the UI I don't really like this like
[creator] radar up here it feels pretty unnecessary but everything else looks
[creator] pretty nice keep crashing and everything I guess we'll see if I can get leveled
[creator] up here there still is like no gravity though like eventually like these
[creator] smaller pieces should just like automatically start floating towards me
[creator] because I'm the bigger body but I'm sure that's something I could end up getting
[creator] updated nice animation there like the sound effects but yeah having all these
[creator] outlines is kinda annoying
[creator] I don't really like it this is just going crazy so definitely gonna be removing the radar
[creator] don't really know why I added that
[creator] explosions are pretty cool the game
[creator] just restarted so what is happening
[creator] alright this is not really playable I don't know
[creator] what's happening why is everything just flying down this way
[creator] I can't even tell what's going on opus did not cook with this not gonna lie I
[creator] think the the 2d version is better I like the UI better on this but like what
[creator] am I looking at this is not playable yeah so I think I'm just gonna stop
[creator] there maybe maybe I can make it keep the sound effects let's see if I do do low
[creator] does that change anything not really it's just it's not good i had higher hopes but i think it
[creator] may have over cooked a little bit here this is very overwhelming like what is happening
[creator] okay well i think that's enough of that oh well the first version was better
[creator] the rest not so great i think the only thing i would do to the first version is just update the
[creator] and add sound effects maybe not worry about all the 3d stuff because well we
[creator] just saw it did not do well with that I'm sure I could spend more time and
[creator] actually make this nice but this is more so just to see if I could actually build
[creator] something with orbit so probably not gonna continue it will say usage
[creator] $446, $409 just on this game which is not playable.
[creator] Granted this is not money I'm actually spending.
[creator] This is what it would be in API credits or tokens but it's just using my clod account
[creator] so I don't have to worry about all that.
[creator] And as far as the usage goes over here I'm on the max plan and I've only used 17% for
[creator] week and I started this two days ago three days ago something like that and
[creator] yeah so I've like hardly put it into it at all now I'm just working on some more
[creator] features for r7 so I guess I could I could show that real quick just close
[creator] out of this actually and we're going to do this guy dev and I guess we could
[creator] Open source tool is for whiteboards, but
[creator] So I gotta figure that out a little bit
[creator] The goal here is to actually be able to have agents
[creator] Create workflow or not workflows, but I'm gonna guess workflows too, but diagrams charts
[creator] I can add and create like mood boards here for what I like and then have those agents actually reference it here
[creator] so I don't have to go into the actual repo, drop in files.
[creator] It just gives me an idea of some stuff I could do.
[creator] You can also create multiple boards, which is pretty cool.
[creator] And then there are some settings that are new.
[creator] Sounds, here we go.
[creator] So if an agent is waiting on me,
[creator] I will hear this ding here, that bell.
[creator] If Orbit needs me, I'll hear this.
[creator] And then when an agent is done with the task, then if an agent hits a problem, I'm probably
[creator] going to have to make these louder though, yeah, and I can also have the agent speak
[creator] out loud so it will say whatever its name is, in this case like Atlas needs you.
[creator] So it would say that with one of the voices here if I have this turned on, I hate that
[agent_tts] This is how I will read answers to you.
[creator] voice, I kind of hate all of these but you know it's whatever.
[creator] It's a lot better than using systems, because that's pretty bad.
[agent_tts] This is how I will read answers to you.
[creator] I could always plug in 11 Labs if I wanted to, but I don't know, maybe I'll do that
[creator] so I can actually have R7's voice in here, that could be cool.
[creator] But alright, that's it.